let's go to five headlines
[Music]
okay the rnc happened last night as you
might expect i didn't watch but based on
the highlights after the fact i say that
the best moment um wasn't any address
given by any politician but
instead the short remarks from the
mccloskeys now that's the married couple
that
stood outside their homes to defend it
against
a mob that was descending on their
neighborhood is now being prosecuted
for that entirely legal uh act an act
protected by the second amendment and
they were invited to deliver a message
and i thought it was short and to the
point and pretty powerful listen
america is such a great country that not
only do you have the right to own a gun
and use it to defend yourself but
thousands
of americans will offer you free advice
on how to use it
at least that's what we experienced what
you saw happen to us
could just as easily happen to any of
you who are watching from quiet
neighborhoods
around our country and that's what we
want to speak to you
about tonight that's exactly right
whether it's the defunding of police
ending cash bail so criminals can be
released
back out on the streets the same day to
riot again
or encouraging anarchy and chaos on our
streets
it seems as if the democrats no longer
view the government's job
as protecting honest citizens from
criminals
but rather protecting criminals from
honest citizens
not a single person in the out of
control mob you saw at our house
was charged with a crime but you know
who was
we were and those are exactly the kinds
of messages that the republican party i
think needs to amplify
and so far at their convention they are
which is great it wasn't all smooth
sailing though it seems that a few of
the speakers forgot
that there was no audience and which
which is tough okay it's like it's
especially if you don't do any public
speaking you might not it might not be
entirely obvious why it's uh so
difficult why this is like an extra
challenge of not having an audience when
you're giving a speech because
you just have to calibrate things
differently it's an entirely different
you know environment when you don't have
an audience to play off of you don't
have the you know applause and
everything
so i think some of the speakers forgot
that and
went for the screaming raucous pep rally
speech
in spite of the fact that there was no
screaming raucous pep rally audience
there kimberly guilfoyle for example
turned the dial up to 11 for her speech
which normally i'm all in favor of
but it didn't quite work given the
crickets in the background watch
watch a clip of this ladies and
gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
that's that's rough that's uh it's
pretty hilarious actually in a really
uncomfortable
the office sort of way in fact it
reminds me of that scene i don't know if
you're if you're an office fan you know
you must have thought immediately the
same thing i did which is the swing the
scene of dwight
at the salesman convention getting his
award uh
really there's major vibes of that going
on
um but the effect is it's it's really
it's like if you went back
watching a speech without an audience
it's it's like if you went back and
watched an episode of like king of
queens
without the laugh track so it's you know
a scene
where kevin james gets caught uh eating
from the jar of mayonnaise or whatever
and then his wife berates him and
verbally abuses him for three minutes
a scene like that without the cue of the
crowd laughing
would be like depressing and disturbing
and it would make you want to call the
police about about the domestic abuse
but with the crowd telling you this is
funny laugh it has a whole different
flavor to it so same here with the
convention speeches
you don't realize how important the
psychological cues of the crowd
are until you don't have it so we are
sheep is what i'm trying to tell you
we react to things emotionally based on
how other people are reacting
they tell us how we're supposed to react
and then we react that way okay
number two a guy named
granda says that he has been in a
throuple
sort of with jerry falwell jr and his
wife for many years now
he's also a business partner of fall
wells to make things weirder
and to make them even weirder from what
i understand
uh the business partnership started
after
the thrupal business not that it would
be much better if it was before but i
don't know it's just weird like you're
in a this kind of arrangement
and and then you decide to start a
business together
um so he says the couple met him when he
was a pool boy
and it's really actually a pool boy and
then he soon started a relationship with
falwell's wife and then and then
falwell uh will watch
uh you know as they're involved in in in
their activities as he's involved
in an activity when i say in an activity
i don't mean playing monopoly okay you
get my drift
but uh he's involved in in that with the
wife and then falwell
will watch uh so falwell's literal
cuckhold
if this is true now the board of
directors at liberty have asked falwell
to resign
uh he originally said he was going to
and then said he wasn't
and but now from what i understand he
really is resigning
and this is all coming on the heels of
of of of that picture of him
with his pants unbuttoned on the yacht
with the young woman
and then uh and then if you recall he
called into a radio show to explain it
and he really
seemed to be drunk or out of it in some
way when he was on the radio show
so it's been one humiliating episode
after another and normally i would say
that this is salacious gossip it's
irrelevant
uh who cares and that's still how i feel
like i don't care that much
but the problem here is that falwell is
was a powerful christian leader
quote-unquote christian leader
big scare quotes on that and he made
millions of dollars
by cultivating that brand and selling it
to the public
and convincing you know people to send
uh their kids to his school
a school where by the way many kids have
been expelled
for doing exactly the kinds of things
that he was apparently doing
all the time in his private life if you
do that
uh and then it turns out that you're a
degenerate weirdo
well then your degeneracy is news
and that's really your fault i don't
feel at all sorry for you
you you you profited off of cultivating
a brand that was completely false and
you treated your faith like a brand
made a lot of money off of it and now
you're exposed that's your fault
and personally i'm i'm so damn tired
of quote unquote christian leaders
turning out to be scumbags that i just
i have no sympathy for them no appetite
to defend them not that i would defend
them anyway but i
you know just uh you want to mock them
and laugh at them go ahead
really they deserve it i'm so tired of
this
i'm not surprised by it that's sort of
my point i wish i was surprised
i wish i was surprised that someone like
jerry falwell jr
is this not at all none of us are it's
what we come to expect
and it really shouldn't be that way um
all right let's go to number three
here's an interesting video it appears
that black lives matter scumbags were
marching through dc i think it was it's
the claim online is that it's d i'm not
sure what city this is but
they were apparently demanding that
people at uh the restaurant you're about
to see here
raise their fists for black power and
one brave couple refuses to act like a
trained seal
responding to commands and this is what
happened because of that
huh
yes be that couple that's the couple you
should be uh those are brave people who
retain their dignity
now personally i would have loved to see
them raise the fist
and then slowly turn it around and raise
the middle finger you know i
i would have that would have been fun if
they had done that but
this was good too so be them
do not be the embarrassing mustachioed
coward to the right who you probably
noticed uh with
sitting there with his fist up you know
and just that look of
total shame on his face
how do you live with yourself after that
you've got this mob
of of scumbags just shouting at you
telling you to bark on command like a
dog
and you actually do it
and it's on film i mean how do you live
with that
totally embarrassing he's given up his
dignity forever uh and it's it's really
not worth it
so good for that couple and that's how
everybody should respond
i mean it really doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what they tell you to do
you gotta this this
this you know mob of bullies coming back
and say hey do this
dude perform this act right now because
i told you to
i don't care what it is you should
refuse to do it
on the principle of it who who do you
think you are i'm not going to listen to
you
why should i listen to you why why
i don't care at all what your opinion is
of me
all right very important report here
from the new york post uh it says while
older texters
may consider the period uh in an
innocent symbol that a sentence has
ended
digital natives consider it a triggering
form of aggression
the punctuation problem ignited over
social media recently with gen z
millennials agreeing that
ending a sentence with a period is
overly hostile
and worse yet extremely uncool um
digital culture journalist victoria turk
in her book
kill reply all it's a book on digital
etiquette so you go pick that up
said only old people or troubled souls
put periods at the end of every sentence
the younger generations consider the act
of sending a text a sufficient
signifier of a complete thought terk
wrote making periods feel
unnecessary and overly final um
okay and it's a long it goes on from
there we could keep reading but i won't
i just have to say you know i can just
sum it up i'm actually in full agreement
with this um and i thought this was
common knowledge
that periods
in a in a paragraph or a series of
sentences are fine of course
very much advised in that case but a
period after
one word or one sentence and then sent
via text messages or message or email is
passive-aggressive
and this is simply a fact i thought
everyone knew that
and since we're canceling punctuation
marks i would also like to throw in
speaking of aggressive punctuation marks
the exclamation point
i think also deserves to be on the ash
sheep of history exclamation points are
almost never necessary if you want to
communicate enthusiasm
you're excited about something you
should be able to do that
via the words you're typing you should
be able to express yourself
in a way that makes your enthusiasm
clear without needing the exclamation
point
and this is especially true of men
okay it's women can get away with
exclamation points
children can get away with excellent if
you're a grown man you should never be
using an exclamation point
except sarcastically or ironically those
are pretty much the only times where
it's acceptable
speaking of dignity no grown man can
keep his dignity
while sending an exclamation point and
that is also just a simple fact five
finally another thing
um here that gets my full endorsement in
agreement report from sky news that says
kiev's kfc will
suspend its finger licking good slogan
after 64 years
because it doesn't quite fit with
coronavirus hygiene messaging
the u.s fried chicken chain has released
new images of advertising posters and
packaging
with the slogan blurred and pixelated
it says colonel sanders is its
finger-licking good saying will return
when the time is right
but we'll alter its messaging for now
because they're you know they're worried
about
the chronovirus this is good and
responsible i'm i'm on board with it
and it has nothing to do with
coronavirus for me
just in general people who lick their
fingers
after eating are disgusting savages
unfit for human society
it may in fact be the number one most
nauseating personal habit a person can
possibly have
it's it's barbaric and the worst thing
is
how many people after licking their
fingers
actually go and wash their hands their
fingers are now
covered in their own slobber how many of
those people are going to wash their
hands
very few of them because they think
their saliva
is sufficient they're like cats thinking
they can clean themselves with their own
tongues
i hate to see how they clean the rest of
their bodies i don't know if they're
like in the shower with the shower
turned off spitting on themselves
washing in the mucus with a with a
loofah i i don't know
but this just to be clear we are human
beings our saliva is not sterile
okay there's all kinds of germs in it
it's completely disgusting
we have invented you know we live in a
civilized world we have running water in
faucets
wherever you are there's probably one
nearby even if you don't have access to
a faucet
there's still no excuse to lick your
fingers
so i'm i'm uh this has been my
[Music]
i've been boycotting kfc really for for
years just because of this slogan
i think it's the most offensive slogan
from from any company i'm glad they're
finally getting rid of it
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated